you can look me you're in the pool
what's happening basically we were just
like in the pool
security guard was like everybody out of
the pool
oh so what tell me about that what did
you see from there nothing much I just
heard like a big bang and then I looked
up and he asked me like what's going on
because we thought maybe their accident
happened to the pool or something that's
why we're getting out and then
saw somebody throw like an object and I
was like oh that's why and then we kind
of just scurried out of there from one
of the hotel rooms yeah do you know what
the object looked like
I think
chair or something
okay did you see the broken window yeah
what kind of damage did that look like
it was like completely
there was like a curtain covering it but
you could